à droite la mère biologique
à gauche la famille adoptive
j'ai été adopté le 7 mars 1996 en
colombie par un couple franco colombien
18 ans plus tard je retrouvais ma
famille biologique pour y parvenir
certains enfants adoptés passe par des
orphelinats d'autres engage des
détectives privés ou encore s'expose à
des émissions de téléréalité moi je les
ai retrouvés par un autre moyen que vous
découvrirez par la suite je m'appelle
gabriela j'ai 19 ans et je suis ici pour
vous raconter de mons temps avant cela
laissez moi vous présenter quelques
personnes lisent clinton nelson mandela
steve jobbs superman bien encore john
lennon vous les connaissez tous j'ai un
point commun avec toutes ces personnes
nous avons tous été adoptés haut placés
et un oeil au moment où nous sommes
réunis aujourd'hui ça d'après midi ici à
paris beaucoup d'enfants perdent leurs
parents d'autres attendent une famille
ils sont près d'un million cinq en
europe et en asie que la cause soit à
l'abandon ou la séparation forcée
la mère biologique a rarement voulu
cette situation et leur calme
lorsqu'elle prend cette décision c'est
avant tout pour donner un futur à son
enfant tous ici vous êtes tous demandé
acquiesce que vous ressembliez le plus
quand il était petit et si vous n'y
pensiez pas il avait forcément un ami
bienveillant ou bien encore le boulanger
ou pan de la rue pour chercher cette
ressemblance avec vos parents alors il
vous suffisait de monter une heure ou
deux dans grenier et puis plonger votre
relevé dans
les albums photo de famille pour y
trouver la réponse ce sont des questions
que je me suis posée - petit et
occasionné des réponses que 18 ans plus
tard les parents adoptifs se sont
rencontrés au mexique à un coup de
foudre alors ils avaient pour projet
d'avoir des enfants biologiques puis
d'adopter par la suite la vie a fait
qu'ils n'ont pas pu avoir d'enfants
biologiques rapidement et les années
passant ils ont décidé de sauter cette
étape et d'adopter deux ans plus tard ma
mère adoptive a reçu un appel une petite
fille de quatre mois l'attendait de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique
cette petite île c'était moi alors le
jour de mon arrivée tous mes proches
étaient là la famille était là et les
photos traduisent de la magie qui
étaient là elles aussi nous avons repris
la villa où mes parents la vie lycée à
paris j'ai enfin ce paisible avec
l'arrivée d'un petit frère un mois et
demi plus tard nous avons connu d'autres
à déménagement en brandissant des
disputes deux frères et soeurs comme de
tout le monde en connaît et puis les
problèmes de famille mais jamais nous
n'avons remis en cause notre lien
fraternel
les premières interrogations si on
arrivait à l'école encourent en cordage
l'été cette matière que je déteste sens
et vie de la terre
on étudie à l'hérédité alors mon voisin
de droite disait moi j'ai les cheveux de
ma mère et de mon voisin de gauche je me
disais moi j'ai la couleur d
mon père et moi plein d'interrogations
ce soir là je suis rentré chez moi et
j'ai dit à ma mère et moi à qui est-ce
que je ressemble en bondissant mes
interrogations sont devenues
omniprésentes
j'en avais plus doux doux je viens à qui
est-ce que je ressemble pourquoi est ce
que je suis dans une famille adoptive et
non pas à ma mère biologique et à l'âge
de saison on l'a reçu une invitation car
la fondation via laquelle mes parents
m'ont adopté s'appelle fana elle a eu
notamment une antenne en france qui
organise les rencontres pour les parents
et les enfants ayant adopté ou adopter
pour qu'ils parlent des adoptions et mes
parents ne souhaitent pas du tout adepte
de ces réunions car cela attriste
beaucoup ma mère affectif de savoir que
la colombie n'a pas les moyens et les
ressources pour s'occuper de ses enfants
colombiens
mais moi à 16 ans j'ai demandé à aller à
lui aussi rencontre sur vous les
rencontrez des gens comme moi qui se
posait cette question alors on m'y a été
et ce jour là j'ai fait de rencontre
fondamentale
j'ai rencontré deux filles qui avait 16
ans comme moi alors forcément on a parlé
de l'adoption
je leur ai demandé comment est ce
qu'elle vivait l'art adoption et elles
m'ont répondu qu'elle avait très mal
qu'elle éprouvait celle rockeur envers
leur mère biologique ce que je ne
comprenais pas du tout parce que moi
j'étais heureuse dans ma famille et je
le vis très bien malgré vos
interrogations
alors forcément quand on est adolescent
on ne sait pas ce qu implique un enfant
c'est parce qu'ils sont d'éducation dit
là
celui ci est ce jour là j'ai réalisé
j'ai compris ce que je voulais dire à ma
mère biologique j'ai compris pourquoi
est ce que je voulais la retrouver je
voulais la remercie et lui dire que
j'allais bien que j'avais des parents
aimants
alors ensuite j'ai grandi et en
attendant patiemment 18 ans qu'à la
législation que l'on vienne oblige
attendons la majorité pour entamer ses
recherches pour assurer le bien-être de
l'enfant et qu'il ne soit pas perturbée
pendant son évolution
alors ma majorité approchons jeu je me
rappelle d'un certain décalage avec mes
amis car la lune 18 18 ans pour certains
c'était l'année du perry c'était l'année
de la libération
pour d'autres ce dès la première cuite
la première discothèque et moi les 18
ans était le jour où vous pouvez
rencontrer safari rencontrer mes parents
ce qui m'avait donné la vie alors le
jour de mes 18 ans arrive j'étais
anxieuse j'avais peur j'étais heureuse
d'avoir 18 ans et je savais que je
trouve entamé ses recherches
alors mon corps est pas raison de me
disais que seule chose c'est à temps car
tu as conscience de chamboulements que
ça va créer chez toi et tu dans ta
famille mais mon coeur me disais qu'une
seule chose
qu'attends tu fonces d'avant je vous
dise le tank pourquoi 18 en plus après
tout alors j'ai entamé ses recherches
j'ai commencé par fans à l'orphelinat
puis par les services sociaux combien
qu'il abbas appelle les biens vestale ce
qui veut dire bien-être en français
qu'il est totalement paradoxal alors
j'ai attendu et un mois après deux jours
avant noël j'ai reçu un email un email
seront iphone alors on voit les deux
premières lignes qui est l histoire
d'adoption et de louisa ramirez alors
c'était moi ça qu'il a cédé moi je
découvrais mon nom de famille j'ai pensé
c'est là paris pour les études et mes
parents vivent à belfort
j'ai préféré attendre d'être avec eux
pour partager cette découverte car après
tout c'est aussi leur histoire a eu
alors nous avons ouvert cet email nous
avons lu céline nous avons parcouru
s'est lui pas j'ai pu mettre des
circonstances sur mon abandon j'ai pu
mettre un âge sur cette femme est un
prénom
la femme qui m'a donné la vie s'appelle
diana elle a 36 ans aujourd'hui
alors des milliers de questions traversé
l'esprit je ne savais pas comment entrer
en contact avec cette femme c'était la
question que j'avais maintenant alors
une femme de l'orphelinat devait la
retrouver deux mois après elle me disait
qu'elle était introuvable
alors je ne savais pas comment faire je
voulais lui parler
j'avais un numéro de téléphone j'avais
une ville natale une date de naissance
et son prénom
j'ai alors pensé à facebook sur facebook
j'ai épluché plusieurs profils 3
correspondent à un seul
correspondent-elles avec la date de
naissance alors j'ai vu cette photo et
j'ai su que c'était elle je le savais je
le voyais dans ses yeux rieurs mais
maintenant la nouvelle question d'y
arriver était comment lui parle et
d'ajouter en asie lui envoyer un poke on
sait pas
alors c'est décidé vous il ajouté en
année j'ai bien joué dans la ligue et
j'entends des paiements l'acceptation de
sa part tu leurs messages alors elle m'a
acceptée en ami nous étions amis ça nous
étions amis sur facebook a pourtant je
n'avais jamais rencontré
alors j'attends une semaine je ne reçois
pas le message de sa part
alors je décide de lui envoyer un gt
incertaine mais mon message était
spontané et ferme à la fois elle me
répond qu'elle ne sait pas qui je suis
je me sens blessé mais je ne m'arrête
pas et je lui dis que je suivais le 29
novembre 1995 à bogota sous le nom de
louise a alors elle comprend qui je suis
et l'émotion est telle qu'elle écrit
avec des majuscules qu'elle ne s'arrête
pas qu'elle me dit combien elle a pensé
à moi à chaque anniversaire toutes ces
années combien la regrettée de m'avoir
laissé à cette info les premiers mots
sont de la rassurer de la remercier de
lui dire que je suis bien que j'ai des
parents qui même jeu foot que j'ai un
frère et que mes parents respectent mon
passé et mon ado sud alors ce jour là
nous faisons connaissance nous faisons
connaissance et peu à peu je regarde son
profil facebook pendant qu'elle me parle
je tombe sur cette photo je vois diana
au milieu je vois un petit garçon plus
jeune que moi et je vois cette fille là
je vois cette fille qui paraît plus âgés
que moi qui vois aussi cette légende les
gens qui me paraît provoquant ce ougna
familière feliz une famille heureuse en
france est alors je me dis
comment pouvait-il affiche de ce bonheur
familial alors que moi j'ai vite
abandonné comment pourquoi est ce que
j'avais été abandonné et pas vu c'était
des questions que je me posais et auquel
devait adhérer 10 alors le jour arrive
dans le jours passent et peu à peu au
fil des jours des semaines je reçois
plein message les besoins des oncles des
tantes et proches des amis
la meilleure amie de diana et caetera et
je vous dis qu'est ce que c'est beau
d'avoir une deuxième famille qui vous
accueille comme ça à bras ouverts alors
damien me dis que la fille qui est à
droite pour cette photo est en fait ce
masseur et le petit garçon qui est à
côté et un bien un de mes demi-frères
j'en ai trois alors les mois passent et
je fais connaissance avec toutes les
personnes qui m'ont envoyé un message
jeudi connaissance avec la nouvelle
farine sa nouvelle famille qui était de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique et avec qui
j'étais liés par le sang j'entreprends
peu à peu de partir en colombie pour
toucher qu'on devrait cette nouvelle
famille
alors mes parents adoptifs sont rassurés
et n'ont pas peur que je parte
un mois tout seul en colombie pour
retrouver cette famille car ils savent
très bien que pour eux et pour moi cette
femme que vous voyez là s'appelle
patricia et c'est ma mère adoptive
je lui ressemble beaucoup et les
pourtant je n'ai pas de lien biologique
avec mon père bruno c'est cet homme à
qui je ne ressemble pas du tout
physiquement mais de dijon tient ce fort
caractère et mon frère je n'en ai qu'un
il s'appelle
bien et j'ai grandi avec lui avec
l'énorme publicité alors le voyage se
préparer comme ge a préparé chaque
détail chaque jour chaque chaque
événement qui vais je faire là bas je
cherche avec mes parents adoptifs le
lieu parfait le lieu propice pour cette
rencontre avec diana nous pensions alors
à l'orphelinat
je pense à elle c'était une manière de
pour elle de clore ce chapitre ce
chapitre douloureux de sa vie sur de
belles retrouvailles avec moi alors je
viens d'un rendez vous avec un
psychologue alors fait l'un pour pour
l'été qui arrive mon départ arrive très
vite et les onze heures de vol aussi
j'ai déjà fait ce voyage plusieurs fois
car ma mère adoptive et colombienne il
ya sa famille là-bas pendant ces onze
heures de vol nous avons l'habitude avec
mon frère de regarder tous les films
possibles
non j'ai bousculé gratuit et de dormir
surtout je passe les onze heures de vol
silencieuse je ne garde qu'un film et je
pense je réfléchis j'essaye j'essaie
d'anticiper cette rencontre avec alain
d'imaginer les premiers mots que je lui
dirai qu'elle me dirait j'étais anxieuse
avait hâte
j'étais mort alors on arrivé là bas ma
grand mère était là mon oncle et mes
cousines étaient là c'est la famille du
côté de ma mère adoptive colombienne
mais je choisi de passer deux jours avec
eux ces deux jours sont un sas pour moi
il me permettre de les rassurer et de
leur dire qu'ils ont une place dans mon
coeur qui ne changera pas de répondre à
leurs questions le troisième jour je
rencontre masseube passé en biologique
cette soeur à qui je ressemble
nous passons la furie des ensembles cet
après midi nous la façon à vous raconter
nos 18 ans mon premier amour
nos expériences et il ya nouveau jeu ne
fuit pas c'est un choc en choc de
cultures un choc deux pays ma soeur a 21
ans aujourd'hui j'en ai 19 l arrivée les
études je fais des études de droit et ma
soeur a deux enfants et moi c'est pas du
tout pour maintenant alors j'ai fait
connaissance avec elle et nous avons
conscience nous réalisons de la chance
que nous avons de pouvoir nous retrouver
comme ça à 18 ans après après 18 ans
d'attentes et nous savons que pour rien
au monde nous avons gâché cette
opportunité et que plein de choses nous
attendre le lendemain le quatrième jour
j'avais rendez vous donc à l'orphelinat
avec ce psychologue pour préparer cette
rencontre il tenait donc j'arrive à
l'orphelinat très tôt et j'arrive dans
un établissement qui imagine un
établissement de trois étages avec de
larges au pouvoir dans tous ces couloirs
il y avait des calmes les cadres comme
cela avec une cinquantaine de photos
aucune photo ni dupliquer les photos qui
sont représentées sont tous les enfants
ayant été adoptées ou tous les parents
ayant adopté
quelle était la probabilité pour qu'en
sortant du bureau du psychologue un
calme attire l'oeil photo maty lèye et
que cette photo soit celle d'un couple
auparavant une petite fille de quatre
mois dans la peau aura une infime
probabilité pourtant c'est arrivé alors
je savais que quelques minutes plus tard
j'allais être avec diana cette femme qui
m'a donné la vie et que à des milliers
de kilomètres de moi mes parents étaient
là pensé à moi et les maps ou bannières
dans cette rencontre
alors j'ai retrouvé diana dont là dans
la salle où mes parents m'ont reçue elle
était la leaf est face à moi elle était
belle elle souriait et nous est heureuse
nous sommes à 6 nous avons parlé et puis
dans ces moments là on n'est jamais
préparé à ces premières rencontres
alors quand j'ai vu pour la première
fois je savais pas ce que je lui serre
la main peuvent lui pas de la bise ou
bien je passe un câlin comme si c'était
ma mère j'ai improvisé et les premiers
mots qu'elle m'a dit on étais tu allais
mais monsieur que le jour où je t'ai
laissé et je m'en rappelle comme si
c'était hier
allons nous avons parlé nous avons parlé
de mon passé des circonstances de mon
abandon
elle m'a raconté son histoire et son
histoire qui est la sienne
il ne m'appartient pas de rappeler ici
ni ailleurs
ce que je retiens et que tout enfant
adopté doit comprendre c'est qu'il n'y a
pas d'abandon son histoire cristal ma
soeur et moi sommes mûrs du même père il
l'a reconnu elle et moi
non aujourd'hui il est décédé il
il ya sept ans je n'ai pas pu le
rencontrer diana après cela était avec
un autre homme cinq ans après a eu leur
petit garçon le petit garçon vous avez
vu sur la photo tout à l'heure qui est
mon demi-frère
aujourd'hui il a 15 ans massa aura été
épargné
massart a dû vivre ces circonstances
priest et moi grâce à mon abandon j'ai
été pariés de se passer alors le mois
passent très vite et je fais
connaissance avec beaucoup d'amis de
diana rigg notamment avec mon demi-frère
de 15 ans à 15 ans mon est très jeune a
15 ans pense à boire de l'alcool quand
ça la première petite coquine
alors la filiation biologique ne
représentent que peu d'autres cieux mon
demi-frère de 15 on m'a posé de question
à savoir si jamais la bière et si jamais
le foot
alors il se trouve que oui j'ai la terre
et oui il arrive de regarder le foot de
temps en temps avec mon frère en france
alors s'allier pour lui nous étions
frères et soeurs car nous avions ce
point commun à tout bloquer on ne voit
pas ça très vite et je redoutais dernier
moment j'étais bien mais ça pourrait
être animé la vraie famille en france me
manquait beaucoup
alors la veille de mon départ j'étais à
médiapart nous étions apaisé vous saviez
le temps ferait les choses et
en titre est votre relation je lui ai
dit au revoir nous ne savions pas quand
est ce que nous allions nous revoir mais
nous savions qu'il y aurait une
prochaine fois ma soeur le lendemain la
compagnie à l'aéroport je vous redoutez
les dernières minutes avec m ça donne
envie de l'emmener avec moi en france de
le partager toute cette culture
alors nous promettons de nous revoir et
je vous prends l'avion
à mon retour en france et il ya
maintenant un an qu'il ait pu
s'aventurer
j'entretiens de très bonnes relations
avec diana j'apprends le français à ma
soeur qui apprend l'anglais mon
demi-frère et je n'ai qu'une envie c'est
de leur montrer mon université de leur
présenter ma farine et si je suis ici
aujourd'hui devant vous pour vous
raconter mon histoire pour vous la
partagez
c'est pour vous faire prendre conscience
que l'adoption est aussi une belle
histoire
l'adoption est une formidable remise en
question sur la fratrie la famille les
liens du coeur que l'on apprend à tisser
avec le temps et je veux transmettre ce
message d'espoir de volonté et de
courage à tous les enfants adoptés qui
comme moi pleurons de leur adoption et
les forces plutôt qu'un point merci